The speed of light is
3 times 10 to the
eighth meters per second.
If it takes 5 times 10 to the
second, or 5 times 100, or
however you want to view it,
seconds for light to travel
from the Sun to the Earth, what
is the distance in meters
between the Sun and the Earth?
Express your answer in
scientific notation.
So this is a simple distance
is equal to
rate times time problem.
And I think what they really
want to test is our ability to
manipulate numbers in
scientific notation.
So what is our rate here?
What is the speed of the
thing in question?
Well they tell us right here,
the speed of light is 3 times
10 to the eighth meters
per second.
So we could write that down.
And then what is the time?
They say if it takes 5 times 10
to the second seconds for
light to travel from the
Sun to the Earth,
so that's the time.
And they say what's the
distance in meters?
So I just take the product
of these two things.
The distance is just going to
be the product of 3 times 10
to the eighth and 5
times 10 squared.
Now, what's fun about scientific
notation is that
you can just rearrange the
numbers you're taking the
products of, because that's
just the property of
multiplication, if everything
is just being multiplied,
order doesn't matter.
And so we could rewrite this
right here as 3 times 5, I'll
try to keep the colors the same,
3 times 5 times 10 to
the eighth times 10 squared.
And let's see what happens
to the units.
You have meters per second
times seconds.
Second in the numerator, second
in the denominator,
they cancel out.
And you're left just with
that meters over there.
And that is nice because our
answer needs to be in meters.
The distance in meters between
the Sun and the Earth.
So what's this going to be?
So you have a 3 times
a 5 right here.
That's 15.
And then you have that being
multiplied by 10 to the eighth
times 10 squared.
10 to the eighth times
10 squared, that's 10
to the 8 plus 2.
Or 10 to the tenth power.
So the distance is 15 times
10 to the tenth meters.
Now you might say,
hey, I'm done.
That is the distance.
And that looks like scientific
notation.
I have some number times
some power of 10.
But remember, if you really want
to be formal about your
scientific notation, this number
right here has to be
less then 10.
The way I've written it right
now, it is clearly
not less than 10.
So how can we rewrite it?
Well what's 15?
15 is the same thing
as 1.5 times 10.
So we could write 15
And then it's going to be that
times 10 to the tenth.
And of course, we have
our units there,
meters right there.
And now we're really close.
We have 1.5 times 10.
Or we could view that as 1.5
times 10 to the first times 10
to the tenth.
And then we have 10 to the first
times 10 to the tenth.
That is just 10 to
the eleventh.
So the total distance from
the Sun to the Earth, in
scientific notation, is 1.5
times these guys, which is 10
to the eleventh meters.